when crypto's Golden Boy lost his entire
Empire overnight instead of running away
from the spotlight he ran towards it of
hearing an interview after interview I
mean I'm deeply sorry about what
happened I mean look I I've had a bad
month
um this is not the name for me that is
an understatement he showed signs of
nervousness in this New York Times
interview perhaps the gravity of a
scandal that could be bigger than Enron
hit him many wondered why in the world
he wasn't arrested right away after
losing billions of dollars of customer
funds when his cryptocurrency exchange
FTX collapsed in November it wasn't
until exactly one month and one day
after FTX filed for bankruptcy that
police in the Bahamas arrested SPF in
his luxury home he shared with roommates
at the request of the U.S
hours before SBF had been playing a
video game the U.S Securities and
Exchange Commission has charged him with
defrauding big investors who committed
nearly 2 billion in recent years
scc's chairman Gary Gensler said in a
statement we allege that Sam bankman
freed built a house of cards on a
foundation of deception while telling
investors that it was one of the safest
buildings in crypto
Sam bankman freed reportedly used
billions in customer funds from FTX to
prop up his other company Alameda
research a hedge fund that was in
trouble after trying to bail out other
struggling crypto firms
he reportedly built a back door in ftx's
accounting software that let him move
billions of dollars from FTX to Alameda
without flagging the transactions to
external auditors
SPF has repeatedly denied that he did
anything wrong did you know that these
funds were being funneled to Alameda
what is your answer
I did not know that there is any
improper eye use of customer funds when
the crypto website coindesk revealed the
close ties between bankman Freed's two
companies FTX and Alameda that made
binance nervous
Finance is the world's largest
cryptocurrency exchange that was an
early investor in FTX and subsequently
sold its stake in FTX consisting mainly
of the FTX token ftt that caused the
price of the token to plummet and
resulted in a domino effect of nervous
customers pulling out leading to the
spectacular fall of FTX
along the way billions of dollars of
customer funds also went missing
bankerman freed has said that if he'd
spent an hour a day thinking about risk
management FTX might not have collapsed
his companies thrived on risk risk was
baked into Alameda whose CEO was his
ex-girlfriend Caroline Ellison a 28 year
old Harry Potter loving math whiz I
think like being comfortable with risk
is very important yeah I think we we
tend not to have things like stop losses
I think those aren't necessarily great
risk management tool a stop loss is
designed to limit the maximum loss of a
trade by automatically selling an asset
once it reaches a certain value not
having a stop loss is incredibly risky
yet no one saw the signs of Doom SPF and
his team had everyone fooled he was
called the next Warren Buffett it
certainly didn't help that Superstars
like Tom Brady and Stephen Curry vouched
for FTX with FTX I have everything I
need to buy sell and trade crypto safely
the glitch and glamor hid what some FTX
users call a Ponzi scheme in which the
First Investors are rewarded with money
that's actually been invested by later
investors rather than making money from
a legitimate product or service The
Mastermind of a massive Ponzi scheme
Bernie Madoff ripped off tens of
thousands of people of as much as 65
billion made off was sentenced to 150
years in prison could SPF suffer the
same fate
he is set to be extradited to the U.S
where Federal prosecutors are charging
him with wire fraud wire fraud
conspiracy Securities fraud Securities
fraud conspiracy money laundering and
violating campaign Finance laws
he was the darling of the Democrats
donating Millions to them though he now
says he secretly gave roughly the same
amount to Republicans if convicted he
faces a maximum sentence of 115 years in
prison the fall of one of the largest
cryptocurrency exchanges is another nail
in the coffin of an already fragile
crypto Market that is yet to recover
from the crash in the spring can people
trust crypto ever again is binance safe
the U.S department of justice has been
investigating binance since 2018
including its founder Chiang Pang Zhao
Reuters reported that it has to do with
binance's compliance with U.S anti-money
laundering laws and sanctions
in order to make an informed decision
about whether to invest in crypto it's
important to understand how it works
brilliant is a great way to learn the
math and science behind cryptocurrencies
through Hands-On puzzles on brilliant's
website and app you can learn the
mechanics of maintaining and securing a
cryptocurrency and then you can decide
for yourself if crypto is a fad my
viewers also love brillian's computer
science fundamentals course where you
can learn the fundamentals of computer
science and no coding is required
brilliant is great if you're studying or
if you're already working and want to
brush up on your math science and
computer science skills I personally use
brilliant to improve my critical
thinking skills by going through their
logic courses brilliant is free to try
out if you head to the custom link in my
description
brilliant.org newsthink and the first
200 people who use my custom link will
get 20 off Brilliance annual premium
subscription which gives you access to
all of their course offerings thanks for
watching for news think I'm Cindy Palm